good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Monday June 29th
which means my comedy special comes out
tonight at midnight tonight at midnight
that was actually like a beautiful song
one in which I could hear on the radio
yeah maybe even Claudia that was
beautiful well everyone's gonna
understand all of our inside jokes
starting tomorrow you can get my comedy
special tonight if you've pre-ordered on
iTunes thank you very much and it'll be
available tonight and then after
midnight tonight it's available on a
bunch of different streaming services on
demand you know Direct TV I'll post all
the jargon on my Instagram because I'm
not 100% sure like what dishes you know
but if you're there it's there it's
Scott I mean it's only appropriate that
I'm on dish because I love eating dishes
of all kinds you'll have a great day I
do
well happy Monday I'm feeling refreshed
and rejuvenated I had a fabulous weekend
I did too I had a very weekend D weekend
I feel like I did some meaningful things
I watched some meaningful content I read
some meaningful books and I guess
overall my weekend was quite meaningful
mine was meaningful but also very
productive I got so much work done this
weekend for an upcoming project that I'm
gonna be shamelessly promoting right
after you preorder my comedy special and
we had a wonderful familial meaningful
moment as we got to meet our niece for
the first time we got to meet our niece
and she is everything in the story you
guys it was like not to sound like
sobered and not to compare but I spent I
was like put down other baby no no
that's what I'm gonna say not to compare
but like I spent the whole day with my
niece and it was literally like the best
day of my life like before we left like
I was literally hit tears my eyes I was
just like so happy it was the best day
ever like we hadn't all been together
and so long we hadn't met her niece yet
it was just like so special and I got
home and I felt this emptiness and like
honestly like this can sound so [ __ ]
up and I'm not comparing but like Theo
like wasn't doing it for me anymore and
I'm not comparing you know technical
dogs to babies I know that they're
different it's just you know like the
thing in your life that you can take
care of your child and like Theo was
who's giving me so much love but like
something about it was like missing I
feel like my ovaries were like yeah wow
that is crazy I was not expecting you to
say that I am Wow
I mean is that why he didn't show up for
work today mr. Theodore he didn't show
up for work today because when I brought
him in on Friday look it's just a little
too hot for me to walk with the dog and
a computer to this office I literally
showed up on Friday sofa clamped after
spending so long getting ready thought I
was like hot [ __ ] then I'm like rolling
down the street sweating my ass off
trying out my dog to take a dump outside
our building like it was it was too much
pressure so I had been do the walks
today I'm just I'm it's a little too hot
maybe maybe in the fall feel will start
coming back but to be honest like the
weather's just it's it's stopping me
from you know bringing my dog into the
office and unless you have a dog live in
New York City and are chubby then you
won't know what I'm talking about I know
the things have changed between you and
Thea when you're calling him my dog no
it's just like after meeting my niece
like I don't know nothing will ever be
the same well we met our niece and she's
actually the most fabulous person I've
ever met in my life such personality
like so interesting everything that she
does is so fascinating hi honey
intelligence smells so good oh my god
this smells she smells like heaven
heaven and I mean like when I first got
there I was so delicate like I didn't
wanna do anything wrong like I made
Olivia and Zak like put her in my arm
and by the time I left I was like
throwing that kid around like a football
like I was just so comfortable with her
oh no I'm still so delegation your
delegation mentioned allocation nation
and also like it's hard work on the arms
having a bed yeah but you have to keep
if you're a variety like your right
elbow elevated to the baby's neck is
like fully straight yeah no my arms
we're definitely getting sore from the
time with the knees and I'm just so
happy for Olivia and Zach and I look
forward to spending so much more time
with vineeth me too it's just it's not
me the week weekend so great and I
actually liked being home in the city
and there was actually like a little bit
of action in the city even this morning
there's like tons of traffic which
obviously I didn't miss but it's nice to
see life being breathed back into New
York yes and on Friday we went to an
alfresco lunch Oh fabulous
I didn't see one single road I should
not see feel smell a roach and so it was
really quite enjoyable and lovely and I
was nervous to like get back into
outdoor dining in the city but I'm here
to say like it was all right it was all
right I guess it's very much you know as
we learned in middle school location
location location
like all about the location even though
the restaurant that we had alfresco
lunch at is not one block away from the
place where I had roach lunch but again
I got so many gems people really like
say the restaurant but it's I can't
stress enough how it's not about the
restaurant and after being closed for
months I'm not about to disparage local
bits and says I'm just not thank you
I'm not thank you it was no good it was
definitely like a little tense to be out
of no frescoe lunch you know you're just
like constantly like and people walking
by like stare at you like you're doing
something wrong I'm like this
restaurants open I don't understand no
you're not doing something wrong no it's
just there's a lot of judgment there's a
lot of judgment period which we'll get
into in today's episode oh there was
lots of tea over the weekend spilled all
over the place yes there was um so I
guess we could get right into it and we
think is there anything else I want to
see Santa Monica to recap black Landsman
did you finish a politician did to you
so did I and I watched the worst movie
I've ever seen in my life which I must
talk about okay so so please discuss so
it'll be a nice long show because we
have a heavy TV recap segment what was
the meaningful book oh the redheads book
well I started the redheads book last
night but I also finished such a fun age
which was a really great book and we'll
talk about it more on the redheads
episode because Dana read it - and so
that's fabulous that is our simple
request let's dive right in let's dive
right into the past five stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
absolutely nobody because some former
toasters keep calling up our sponsors
and telling them to stop working with us
therefore we have no sponsors thinking
that's gonna get us to end this show but
little do you know that ads are not the
backbone of the show they never were we
don't care about sponsors we welcome
them of course if you want to email us
Ella hello
at morning Toshio calm but you know what
we don't need sponsors to keep the
lights on here and we thank you so much
for being such a dedicated former
toaster like honestly I can't tell you
how much it means to me that like you
are taking up so much time out of your
day to call our sponsors you could do me
a favor and not attack the black-owned
businesses business owners who are
working with us that would be greatly
appreciated because I know you think
that you are some sort of social social
justice warrior who is going to save the
world by calling all the morning toast
sponsors I totally get that mentality I
really do I'm not only mean sarcastic
like I really do get it like I get being
that angry at two beautiful women I get
beautiful setting and smart I get it but
stop harassing the black owned
businesses who are working with us
because that makes you an [ __ ] and
part of the problem when you think I get
it like you think you're part of the
solution you've gotten so in on the
weeds on being part of the solution
you're actually becoming part of the
problem so stop attacking black on
business owners or I will you don't know
what I'm gonna do so let's not get there
so I got there let's go right in so you
guys can stop watching today's episode
there's no further sponsor oh yeah no
they're gonna keep watching cuz anything
for life yeah if you watch today's
episode no more sponsors so feel free to
go back to the hole that you crawled out
of
and we'll see you tomorrow morning at
10:30 a.m. Eastern Time see you then
okay first story the big story that
dropped on Friday right after we wrap oh
by the way all this like this is what's
happened in quarantine like we changed
no time of our show like by 20 minutes
and literally all the news happens the
second I get out of this chair yeah I
mean it makes sense cuz like we're still
on New York time we're wrapping the show
almost around like 10 20 30 so that's
what we used to get the news but anyway
no time like the present to discuss the
fact that Kanye West is bringing his
easy brand to gap in the most brilliant
news I've read in a while the rap
superstar will design adult and kids
clothing that will be sold at the chains
stores next year they signed a 10-year
deal for a Yeezy line at Gap Kanye has
been a huge fan of gab for a long time
he wants to wear the gap yes he used to
work at the gap he apparently a few
years ago he had he was talking on a
radio show how he had meetings like with
gaff HQ about doing something like this
but it didn't work out but now it's
working out the easy gap is coming
that's so interesting for like you know
Kanye who was really regarded as like a
fashion visionary for like his you know
like dream Club to be with gap because
honestly like the gap is so random I
think this is a great partnership for
cap and a great partnership free easy
and honestly I'm just hoping like this
means more volume because like I've
literally never been able to purchase
something from easy because it sells out
so fast so if working with gap makes it
more accessible like I'm down I think
that that is exactly the what it means I
think it is great for both parties
obviously gap could use a reinvigoration
and Kanye
we'll do just that and also for Kanye it
means distribution getting to the masses
and working for a major major corporate
player and it probably means more
affordable yes right okay so that makes
seventy two hundred dollars and the more
I thought about gap and like where
they're at today and I hadn't thought
about gap in years since the sweatshirts
I hadn't right so I just some more this
makes sense to me like they really are a
basics company that's what he does it's
a lot of those true actually it's like
an old Navy yeah no but they have a
really great brand and I just I think
this is so fabulous also a message went
up last night I saw my Instagram I
wanted to share on the Gap store
um they like put up a sheet with I'm
sure it's not called a sheet um at the
gap store on Michigan Avenue in Chicago
with a message from Kanye did you see
this whoa and he said thank God
hi Shaka go it's yay this is the Gap
store I used to shop at when I would
drive my Nissan from the south side so
blessed I thank God and I am so humbled
at the opportunity to serve I put my
heart into the color palette and every
detail I love trom the original do you
like stuff I don't know what to do with
my hands I wait that's so funny and so
cute I love like a meaningful
partnership where there's like a
roundabout message
we're coming full circle Chicago used to
shop there used to work there and I was
coming back working was gap I love a
full circle I love a meaningful
partnership I think that this is
fabulous
um but can we talk about for a moment
remember those weird few years where gap
was obviously going through something
and they rebranded to like love no you
don't remember that no I don't they have
like they love stores I do not remember
that it was the strangest thing ever
Wow I'm glad that I like didn't pick up
on that no it was it was a thing also
speaking of Kanye did you see the
pictures that Kim posted yesterday I
have the two of them in Wyoming just
looking Extra Terrestrial
Deller yeah you know by the way I live
for them and I die and breathe for them
and everything they do like I consume I
purchased everything but like that
outfit was just not it for me and by the
way you know what wasn't me the scenic
views the house in Wyoming like I'm
colic be the love between two parents it
was beautiful just the outfit wasn't for
me oh the whole photo for me was stellar
yeah
now I just saw it in like alright we're
still in this like robotic vibe it's
just not my particular area of expertise
I would say so um it's just what's my
god okay more like a cotton-blend that's
there
let me today I got this romper on Amazon
love it and I wore it yesterday
antara alfresco lunch and I'm thinking
about buying in some more colors I'm
just really happy if you need it in
black I think that's the best thing you
can do is find something that works for
you in every color
and then you just have this like uniform
sort of I totally agree
like Jeffrey star has his like track
suits I want to come up with like my own
thing you know mm-hmm and it was gonna
be track suits but it's too [ __ ] hot
yeah it's way too hot okay you ready for
our next story some exciting news yeah
is your shirt from revolve yeah I
literally bought it looked so bad I mean
I sent it back
oh it's Nicole Richie how's farlow no
it's not it's um one of their random ass
grants Beyonce's visual album blackest
King is coming to Disney Plus in a
surprise Disney plus announced a new
digital visual album from Beyonce black
is king inspired by The Lion King it's
coming to streaming service next month
black is king written directed and
executive produced by Beyonce will globe
really will globally premiere on Disney
Plus on July 31st 2020 that's just after
that's just after the one year
anniversary of the theatrical release of
Disney's The Lion King remake for which
she voiced Nala fiance the loves of
visual album she does the one-minute
teaser trailer for black as King dropped
on Saturday night on Beyonce calm yes I
watched the trailer um and you know what
I think is really cool about Beyonce is
like she could do anything you know
she's like a global superstar but I feel
like her last couple of projects have
all been and under the mindset of just
like supporting like black artists
supporting supporting black heritage
like black history and it's just like
she could do anything in the world and
all she wants to do is like support her
culture and her heritage like I think
that's commendable yeah I saw a comment
from Tina Knowles that was like this is
what Beyonce has been working on
non-stop like for so long this is
everything to her she's put everything
into this and now I'm really excited to
see it and I think this is gonna be
fabulous speaking of I watched the BT
Awards last night which were virtual and
I feel like it was kind of like the
template for how award shows might be in
the future and to be honest like I
didn't really hate it
that's what we said
out a similar award show recently where
it was like people just sort of showed
up with their camera wards they had a
video menu that they had one in advance
and I know like some award shows are
like so why'd he tidy about that like
they don't want to tell anyone but
honestly it didn't really bother me and
all of the skits Amanda Steel's was the
host and she was so funny and like
instead of doing like little shtick in
between each award should put together
like full-blown skits and they were
really funny and like well produced and
I didn't hate the like the format
interesting yeah it was it was very well
done love to see it yeah love to see
people getting creative in the extended
cute who knows where we'll be during
award season which I think starts in
September yeah but everything's really
pushed back but the Emmys are September
but this place to be hosted by Jimmy
Kimmel I am so curious if he'll step
down the Oscars and the other award show
the Golden Globes were pushed back
towards like April of next year you know
what nothing I'm thinking about it
there's such a similarity between what
Kevin Hart experienced with the Oscars
and like all the backlash and then
eventually stepping down to what Jimmy
Kimmel is experiencing and how there
really hasn't been this like call for
him to step down don't the same thing
and I'm curious if he's gonna end up
hosting it cuz honestly like I don't
agree with what Kevin Hart said but I
would have absolutely loved for him to
host Oscars like I love him and part of
me like still wishes that he would even
though I don't think he ever will and I
think that if Jimmy Kimmel does it like
that's just like no we don't even want
you and like you you met you [ __ ] up
either but his plan right now is to do
it he keeps saying he's taking a summer
vacation and he'll be back for the Emmys
wow really yeah I think Owen archana I I
think haven't heard you do everything we
do okay this is really crazy
Jada pinkett-smith and her son Jayden is
disgusting I did this story like I can't
I'm like embarrassed like it's just
embarrassing it's horrible are disgusted
over youtubers Shane Dawson sexualizing
willow in a video Jada pinkett-smith and
her son Jayden are taking a stance
against Shane Dawson on Saturday the
mother-son pair called out Dawson on
Twitter after an old clip resurfaced of
the youtubers seemingly masturbating to
a poster of Willow Smith when she was 11
Mike Hayden
Jayden's tweets came after
released a YouTube video titled taking
accountability in which he apologized
for his past actions including using
blackface and sang the n-word - Shane
Dawson I'm done with the excuses said
Jada pinkett-smith on Twitter yeah you
know what um we talked a lot about
canceled culture on this show and I
always say and I really stand by like if
you said something bad and like you
really issue like a genuine apology like
we spoke over the weekend about jenna
Marbles like to me like her video like
made me cry like it was really sincere
and it's not excusable for actions but
like to me that shows true remorse and
when before I even knew all the videos
that had come out about chain Das and I
watched his video and I'm like this is
just not in any way a voguing real
emotion for me like it was just so like
I've watched a million peoples other
people's apology videos and I'm gonna
like do a tear a prototype prototype of
what an apology video should be and I
didn't really feel like it was genuine
or sincere and that was before I even
saw the content that's been going around
there's I mean I'm on take talk now and
I have now fallen I told you last week I
was on the trailers website of tick tock
now I'm on the youtubes drama side of
tick-tock it's fascinating it's
fascinating I mean they like everyone
there's all this drama with Gabby Hanna
who I never even heard of there's like
this clip of her that's going viral
where she's calling everyone monsters
and that she's a victim but now I'm
getting clips of the Shane Dawson videos
and they're they're awful like they're
just they're some of the worst I've ever
seen and the one in Willow Smith is
particularly vile and honestly I'm kind
of glad that Willow and Jade I mean Jada
and Jayden um spoke out against it
because it's a really [ __ ] gross oh
you know when I saw the video posted the
first time which I thought was so
interesting Porsha Williams from the
real house is about land I posted and
she was like [ __ ] like disgusting and
it was just like it was such like a raw
reaction from like Oh like a mom and I'm
like actually I really agree with her so
this whole situation is like really
gross and like embarrassing and I kind
of love that Jada spoke up yeah and we
couldn't get through the whole Shane
Dawson video so long with with nothing
but like kept picking his face which he
did all the time on the jeffree star
collab and it bothered me so much but in
this particular video there was nothing
in frame to distract me from him
literally picking out his face so much
it is so gross yeah um I guess the only
really take away that he said that was
semi interesting was that he understands
that he deserves to lose it all he
expects to sort of not come back from
this we'll see what happens but this was
like discussing like abhorrent like and
people love to
I think hear from us on certain issues
especially canceled culture because you
and I were momentarily canceled and I
think we offer a unique perspective on
it and I think people often think that
like we like we're just gonna defend
anyone who was cancelled and for the
most part like I try and really
sympathize with people who are cancelled
because I know what it's like to be in
that kind of situation and there's so
much misinformation being spread about
people in the moment but like I just
want to say like this is where I'm like
I do not stand i do not defend like this
is [ __ ] gross and really
inappropriate and really problematic
behavior like I just I want to make that
very clear yeah I think also when it
comes to canceled culture and us sort of
sticking up for most people who have
been cancelled it's really frustrating
to see like one or a few mistakes define
someone and that's where we sort of take
umbrage also I and I've been seeing this
going around a lot now Kancil culture
versus accountability and how we have to
cancel cancel culture and whatnot so I
and I feel like everyone kind of agrees
with that but no one really knows how to
implement to implement it and so from
what I'm gathering because really this
has been a reckoning for a lot of people
the Golden Girls got in it last last
night right to sort of own up to the
[ __ ] that they've done and apologize and
do by the way and so I think that in
terms of accountability it means holding
these people accountable telling them
that what you did was wrong like seeing
how sorry they actually are but then
also giving them space to grow like she
like and this is something that Jameela
Jamil is always saying like if you don't
give this person the opportunity to grow
if you just shut them down the minute
that you plan for them then you're not
then they won't grow the people who
support it like no one there's no growth
after that that's the entire point of
the human experience is to continue to
grow and you know what I actually had
like such a lame thought toe but
remember when we were younger we used to
sing that song
growing we do it every day oh you're
bribing in the evening and even when we
play and it's just a song I remember
asking like a teacher like to ever stop
like and obviously is that like physical
growth of course of course
and she was like I was like to ever stop
growing at a certain point and she was
like no you Louise girl like a little
bit like Minister Lee won't be able to
measure I mean I always thought that
that meant that I was like always
getting a little taller getting taller
but no it's like it's emotional growth
it's it's knowledge it's you're can't
you we are constantly growing we do it
every day every day we're growing in the
evening and even when we plant and so
like as a as a follower of a lot of
people but then also someone who has
followers I always find like it's not on
okay if somebody makes a joke or let's
say Shane Dawson or Jenna are not
chained awesome because honestly he's
just on the league of his own discussing
this but like jenna Marbles who did ask
it like in 2011 doing blackface it's not
on her white followers like forgive her
it's on the black followers so I just
feel like everyone has their own
experience with a creator with a
celebrity and it's on them to decide
whether or not they want to move forward
and if you don't want to support anyone
anymore of course that is your right and
you were title to it but I just don't
think throwing a party about it is
necessary no I don't think so either and
I and I don't think and I think what
cancel culture is is continually judging
someone years later based on mistakes
that they have from that they have
remorse for and that they have addressed
I agree like but everyone can and should
take accountability for things that's
part of living in the public eye people
are gonna Drudge up things about you and
it's not necessarily fair but it's just
part of the job it's par for the course
and you have to be willing to take
accountability like going dark and like
releasing a statement like that's not
really in my opinion a good way to move
forward yeah you know this is certainly
the moving forward part that's just the
addressing part and that's only half how
you address it and apologize is half and
how you come back is and no and then
what you do after what how your
followers can see that you have grown
and matured they learn from it
yeah like tangible growth tangible
growth visual growth yeah I agree
like I feel like I'm
watching someone different than I used
to agreed and that's all we can hope for
from people honestly we have to be a
little bit more you know realistic yeah
okay this next story um you posted
torian's gram laughing I don't know if I
would have seen it otherwise oh my god
it was everywhere the tiant country
twitter was [ __ ] on fire okay see
we're [ __ ] cutting people's heads off
even in our comments like this pandemic
has made people angry on both sides like
people are [ __ ] angry I was shook at
our art Instagram is normally like a
light funny cute Kardashian place but
the [ __ ] comment section was just
wild and I really encourage people of
course everyone is entitled to their own
opinions but can we all just start
stating them like a little bit more
gracefully yeah I don't know if that's
possible I know it's not possible like I
know that okay well here's the story I
have a lot of thoughts on it so I kind
of just want to unpack it okay um we had
seen that Kelsea Ballerini tweeted
because there was a video going around
from chase Rice's concert that was on
his Instagram story on Twitter it's a
chase rice just played a concert to an
enormous crowd of unmasked fans here in
Tennessee for once I am a loss for words
then
Kelsea Ballerini retweeted that tweet
and said imagine being selfish enough to
put thousands of people's health at risk
not to mention the potential ripple
effect and play a normal country concert
right now at chase rice music we all
want and need to tour we just care about
our fans and their families enough to
wait so at first I saw this tweet and I
felt two ways immediately on the one
hand it's like what are these people
doing like we're in the middle of a
pandemic and there's thousands of people
at a concert like what in the world not
wearing masks not one wearing a mask and
then like a part of me was like excited
and happy that people's lives are
starting to get back to some semblance
of normal so I did a little bit more
research about it TMZ got a statement
from the venue because of course like
when you see this you're like chase rice
didn't make this decision completely on
his own it had to be Lisa yes someone
somewhere allowed him to do this if
these people were breaking the law like
they would have been arrested the
concert would have been shut down if
let's say there was like an ordinance in
Tennessee like no gatherings of more
than 200 people right so the bushi
mountain group that owns the venue told
TMZ that all local requirements were
abided by for the recent concert and
numerous precautions were taken we
drastically reduced our maximum venue
capacity of ten thousand to four
thousand max
capacity which is lower than the state's
advisement of 50% with less than 1000 in
attendance Saturday night providing
ample space in the outdoor lawn area for
fans to spread out to their own comfort
level they added that all guests were
getting temperature checks prior to
entering the venue and free hand
sanitizer was provided to everyone at
entry all vendors and staff were advised
to wear masks and gloves when
interacting with guests and bandanas
were available for purchase on site they
go on to say that they were unable to
further enforce physical distancing
their signage recommended and are
looking for alternatives for future
shows including stanchion dividers and
implementing the drive-in style
arrangement or just postponing concerts
outright so I read this and I was just
like they're technically doing within
the legal limits yeah and you know we're
in month three and a half of this like
eventually things have to start getting
back to what's gonna be a new normal you
know it's never I don't think for a
really long time it's gonna be the way
that it used to be mhm
so I'm looking at this picture and like
obviously they're not wearing masks it's
not good and I was just like what's
going on in this county so I went to I
did some research online because I feel
like we're not getting like you know you
see these pictures but it only tells you
context you know you need context so I
went to the county where this concert
was held I wrote it down because I don't
want to mess this up the county where it
was held has has in total had 23 cases
and one death so I went to the
surrounding counties obviously people
probably drove in it says right then
next county 14 cases no deaths next
County 16 cases no deaths next County
159 cases three deaths next County 43
cases no deaths next skate next county
90 cases two deaths next county 31 cases
one death I even went one circle beyond
that to the next counties and the
numbers are very very similar and I
started thinking about it like we need
to start life needs to resume tomorrow
at some point and if it's not gonna be
in a place like this where the numbers
are really low and they're doing less
than 50% capacity they're getting their
temperatures taken what people do when
they get in there and they take their
masks off and they don't want a socially
distance it's not a chase Rice's fault
not chase Rice's fault and I feel like
Kelsea Ballerini passing judgment on
it's just like we're getting so Shamy
well that I've I I don't know if I doubt
that no I don't know even by the way
even before um like the real thick of
Corona we were always saying like
concerts probably won't be back til the
end of the year so I do think that like
given the cases are going up in the
country which is was expected I do think
it's a little soon for a concert to be
held but I'm not and I if it was in my
town like I probably wouldn't have went
probably but and that's a totally agree
that is my choice I'm sure there are
people who listen to the show who are at
the concert like there's no doubt in my
mind show who completely disagree with
me and maybe that it's irresponsible
whatever is that and there's gonna be
people who are like yeah I mean I mean
that's that was our comments section
last night my problem is it's like I
think that what's going on right now the
problem is that like people feel a
certain way some people are really
extreme and some people are really
extreme on the other side and it's like
the shaming is what I don't agree with
and like the public kind of taking
pictures of everyone and it's like I get
that we're all trying to do the right
thing and this is even when we were
saying about people calling our sponsors
like people who are taking pictures of
other people like walking their dog not
wearing a mask like we're sitting at the
park on a Saturday like I get it like
you really feel like if you take a
picture and post it on Twitter like you
are going to help I get it like I really
do and I get that you feel this kind of
savior like like you're gonna help and
chain these people into thinking the
same way that you do but I don't agree
with that and I don't I don't agree with
people you know who are you know
fighting to not wear a mask like I don't
agree with that but I don't agree with
like also like this public kind of
shaming where you think it's gonna help
change people's mind it's actually
making the divide in our country so much
worse 100 percent so even though I don't
agree with this concert I wouldn't have
went to this concert and I do wish
everyone in the concert was wearing
masks at the same time it's a free
[ __ ] country like if you want to go
to a concert in your county and make
your whole county sick please I'm not
going but go yes but also if you want to
go to a concert in your County if we
ever got to a place in New York City
where we had in even one week not even
in the last three and a half months in
one week 53 cases and zero deaths I
would hope that we would be able to have
an outdoor concert at less than 50%
outdoor yes
oh sure yes I know it looked indoor it
was outdoors I check I double-checked
but let's triple choker um yeah at first
I thought it was indoors too the thing
is you know like I there's a lawn it's
outdoors are you sure it just said and
the statement I just read okay but will
triple check so I just on this story
it's it's not really about for me it's
not about the concert because at the end
of the day like people's decisions are
their own and this was technically legal
it was within the legal limit and people
made the decision on their own volition
to go and I can't disagree with someone
else's decision I just like I feel like
as a country like we have got to calm
down you know on both sides like
everyone needs to chill the [ __ ] out
it's really scary it's really scary the
the shame enos obviously people who are
like throwing tantrums in a supermarket
about not wearing nuts or nothing I'm
not talking about those people and
coughing on people like that's insane
I'm not talking about those people I'm
just talking about like the everyday
shaming like even like within friend
groups like I just think we need to
chill yeah we definitely need to chill
and I also feel like wearing you work
obviously we're in the globe ik of the
center and so what they're doing in
Morgan County Tennessee has absolutely
nothing to do with what we're doing here
I would not leave my house here I mean I
wouldn't there's no concert for me to go
to I might leave my house without a mask
but it's just it's different I actually
was thinking about and I'm like us going
to the Celine Dion concert at Barclays
10 days before the quarantine went into
effect is actually way more dangerous
than them going to this concert with 53
cases zero deaths in the county yeah and
with a top of mind they all got their
temperatures peak and there's hand
sanitizer like every even obviously in
that picture where they're all singing
like it doesn't look like it's half of
mine but we went to Barclays where
everyone still thought that the corona
virus was a flu you know one had hand
sanitizer on them everyone's touching
every surface and it was it was out
there and we didn't even know yeah well
I knew I didn't touch a thing but
honestly I was like literally I saw a
million toasters I was like look in
their faces I always honestly like the
probably the moat if I don't get
coronavirus they're like I think I'm a
mutant like I was just like I was having
so much fun I went to dinner and I was
with TBG and Margot OSIS like all these
house I said I was taking pictures for
Margaret Martin was taking pictures like
it was just that probably did most
Jeremy I'd ever been and like I probably
didn't even shower when I got home I got
straight into bed so honey my night was
like this
ha ha I was like this the whole time I
didn't even pee while I was there yeah I
didn't want to go to the bathroom but
like anyways no but here's the question
about this entire situation and I think
probably what people aren't thinking
about the most is you know it's one
thing go to a concert for sure but it's
like of course there's risks when you're
leaving your house like it's Jason rice
worth it
I don't know it was a Luke Holmes
concert I'm even think this would be a
story because obviously it's worth
getting sick going to see outcomes but
she's right he's got a few good songs
but I don't if he's really worth it he
actually have a lot of good songs and
thanking him and he's so hot like I
totally get it that was just a joke I'm
kidding yeah that's what everyone's like
commenting about you risked it all for
chase rice I think he just shows how
much people want to go to a concert and
listen I know a lot of people are gonna
disagree with me I welcome that I think
it's like discourse is important but
it's starting to feel like everyone just
like like and I honestly I think Kelsea
Ballerini like shaming him like this and
not really realizing like what went into
putting this concert on and the fact
that they're following the guidelines
which you know is all you can ask would
you look at all right I think it's lame
yeah I just I just think honestly like
what type of death wish she just chased
right Bryce has for his career because
he knew doing this was not gonna be a
popular I mean of course I mean you have
to take the temperature of the culture
right now like people are so angsty and
ready to just jump on someone who they
think is gonna like perpetuate the virus
yeah well I also saw in my research that
there had been some other like country
stars like small country stars who are
doing concerts like this and I don't I
don't know I I have to imagine if he
thought he was doing something wrong
like yeah I guess you can't hide a
concert right well then also think about
for the duty mantra Dave Chappelle
Netflix special so that was technically
a concert it was held outdoors but it
was seated and it was two people six
feet apart like it was much more
civilized people were not standing it
was not GA so there is a way to do it
where I think people would be okay with
it cuz nobody was outraged about Dave
Chappelle cuz they it was it was
literally in a field they were taking
everyone's temperature and literally
each folding chair was 16 apart and
there's only like 30 people so there is
a way to do it where I think people
wouldn't get mad but I just I can't
imagine that chase rice and his
management team didn't see this coming I
just can't you've been a
I guess maybe they wanted that type of
attention impressed they say you know no
press is bad press but I beg to differ
yeah but I also think um you know maybe
we could look at this more positive side
I think this this venue and this concert
would be is an interesting test case to
watch over the next two weeks like a
County a a decent County portion and
it's also just like this eastern
Tennessee area with pretty low cases um
get doing a socially distant up until a
certain point when everyone's concert
like what happens in this area it's a
case study that's an interesting point
so I think I think we can maybe get some
valuable information from it yeah and I
think the fact that they all got their
temperatures taken before they went in
is very important yeah even though the
CDC has been very like wishy washy on
whether or not like you can be
asymptomatic and give it to someone they
said you can and then you can't I just
feel like there is so much
misinformation there's just so many
misinformation it's so confusing so I
think people are just like alright I
don't know the truth like I'm just gonna
stay in my house no I or I don't know
the truth I'm gonna do what I think is
best
sure um also I'm sure you saw that movie
minute like Joe Rogan posted awhile ago
that was like the CDC and the who I
don't know [ __ ] about it and people like
and you know what honestly I looked at T
V G a lot because to me he's like the
smartest person in my life and he
travels so much and he's just like
second smartest sorry hurtsfoe second
smartest person and he's been traveling
and like just showing what the type of
you know different um measures are being
taken in different airports and TSA
lines and on the planes and he keeps
citing like the WHO and the CDC and like
I'm just like I know this sounds really
time like I don't get it like I don't
get I don't know maybe it's just me like
I don't know what's going on and like
it's not like I'm misinformed like I
read a lot but there's so much missing
literally like two headlights completely
saying different things like it's just
it's honestly like disheartening to feel
like you want to know what's going on in
the world and you literally can hey
there's so much confusing misinformation
things that were said that now are taken
back like we were even talking about
like the the masks how in the beginning
no one you were shamed for wearing a
mask because it should have gone to
health care work health care worker and
also I remember when I was
wearing in January I was wearing those
like flimsy little surgical masks on the
box it says that you need to switch out
this mask every four hours or else it
stops working on a and someone had DM me
and said you actually need to switch
them out every 30 minutes people have
been wearing it's not sure we excuse me
I'm minding them like my mother-in-law
gave me like one of those surgical masks
that they sell there they're not selling
them in Ziploc bags three for $10 at
bodegas in New York City I have since
the beginning of quarantine I have the
same one now I wear like my toast man I
got like a tie-dye one but like that
surgical mask when I walk the Oh like I
wear it every day so that's what I'm
saying it's just like we're shaming
people for rank nests and then for not
wearing masks and it's just confusing so
I think we all just need to let up a
little bit on other people because we're
making the divide in this country yeah
it's worse and I think that in the
beginning of quarantine like it was
something we're all in this together and
like we were coming and it felt like
something that was gonna like bring this
country together that's what I was
thinking about on the toilet this
morning because I was thinking about you
know the the stories of the day and I
was like remember that time when dr.
Burks came on our show and she was like
honestly what's been so pleasantly
surprising about this whole thing is
like people from the private sector the
public sector both sides of the aisle
Republican and Democrat are just coming
together to work together and honestly
like it almost brought a tear to my eye
like it was beautiful and now I feel
like we are in a different country yeah
it's just really sad so I don't know
maybe the concert but if you want to go
go like do what you want to it's your
life yeah it's your life what's she
gonna do the world is watching you every
day the choices you make say what you
are and who your heart beats forth it's
in a bender it's your life what you
gonna do what a great Christian song
from a Jewish singer okay
fifth and final story Sheena Shay's
boyfriend pens a supportive message to
her after her miscarriage I just have to
say before you dive in in the last six
months like I have turned into like a
scheana Shay number-one fan it has been
transformative this mission is the
hardest working woman on Bravo she
nobody has been through more [ __ ] and
you know what maybe and not even a lot
of people are talking about this story
about where she shared that she had a
miscarriage and maybe that's because
Bravo wouldn't air the footage that they
filmed of her getting her eggs freezed
for
remember they didn't area no she that's
what she was complaining about on
Twitter like they did a little nod she'd
remember she told Lala at the party
y'all I feel like I was there no but
there was like so much footage of her
actually going through the surgery it's
gone
justice for Sheena [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay I'm just gonna say like I'm not mad
that no but I think that Matthew Tinsley
and her eggs like a Tory thing on Bravo
has been ruined no but all I'm saying
it's like I feel like this isn't a big
enough story yeah well you know what
she's in a really happy relationship
right now and her boyfriend had some
very sweet words to share on his
Instagram after she revealed that she
had a miscarriage he said she has my
back and I have hers he captioned a
really cute picture of him honestly like
look at that no okay so that he is like
a bodybuilder and she all she does is
like take pictures of him with his ass
like bear and and I kind of shake that
challenge on tick-tock words all over
him no it's exactly what she's always
been looking for just like this man Prok
who loves her I think I'll be in like
tick-tock and YouTube videos with her I
think that this is the end of the road
for scheana Shay like I really feel like
this relationship to God see I just I
have a feeling about it and I hope I'm
not I do have a feeling about it too I
was really sad to hear that she suffered
a miscarriage I would have I'm like she
seems like she's very eager to write and
we would know that if she shared some of
her footage on the show but more than
her just being like obsessed with and
dies and so my heart really goes out to
her yeah I think sharing a miscarriage
is like one of the bravest things you
can do over the weekend also something
Navy's Arielle Charnas shared that she
had suffered an ectopic pregnancy which
again is so brave so and so you know
actually I'm Lauren and Ari yeah from
The Bachelor also announced it so I just
think it's really brave my honestly my
hearts with scheana Shay I just I really
love her and I feel like now after years
of like kind of not even like
acknowledging her on the show I feel
this need to protect her yeah I agree
I'm so happy for her new relationship
and hearts are with her those are our
Fast Five stories and now it's time to
dive into the TV recap segment which is
brought to you by nobody so what do we
want to go with first a politician
fabulous fabulous fabulous fabulous is
Bette Midler doesn't get a [ __ ]
any a nomination for this show I will
strike
because she was fabulous she was
excellent I loved the turn that this
took show this the show took I love the
turn that this show took this season
I loved this local New York state
election election of course it was a
little unrealistic does anybody really
care about the New York State Senate
election no somebody running for New
York Senate state Senate like through a
rally would anyone come no no I don't
even know there was a state Senate until
this episode of the bat up the
politician um I just loved it I thought
what if Paltrow's character was
fantastic I just loved everything about
her I did think towards the end of the
series there getting borderline a little
too unrealistic for me like with the
vice president and the president thing
beyond like the whole show has always
been unrealistic even though the state
Senate isn't you know hot ticket no I
honestly is something someone like Ben
Platts countering so as a rest
current student ya know by the way are
there students serving in the state
Senate you only have to be 18 no I'm
that's true but like are there students
serving in this current climate
I could see young people in New York
rallying behind it and and while you
stood out actually that I got past that
quickly you know yeah um it was
extremely unrealistic especially towards
the end like with the tie I hate when
they do that and then also like all it
took was for Judith Light to hear him
sing to just give up her career career
yeah if only she had heard him sing
sooner yeah I think that there were some
episodes in some moments that were
really smart I thought the commentary on
canceled culture was hilarious it was so
subtle and I think that I thought that
in the first season to wear Quentin's
Paltrow was in the train station that
she was life is just a tornado of [ __ ]
and all you have to do is try not get
hit with it and I know and just grab as
many gold bricks as you can and so I
felt like they really commented on the
state of the world in a really smart
subtle way but I felt that even more
this season with just like the extremism
that is canceled culture like when they
all freaked out about the sixth row
picture of him wearing a Native American
headpiece which is obviously cultural
appropriation but at six years old he
obviously didn't know that he was just
dressing up as a character from like a
TV show that he liked like it's just but
the incentives but they see everyone in
there freaking out like it's gonna ruin
his career like that is really what
happens today yeah so it's crazy so I
feel like that that's where I loved the
show there were parts that did fall flat
for me I saw it
I think that what carried this season
was what was going on with the older
people like DD Standish the throuple
they're the throuple and Gwyneth's was
everything this season she was
everything last in last season but she
was even more everything the scenery the
adults really carried the show also been
pot is fabulous as always what was going
on with the kids and like the three
friends agreed and the stupidity of the
day and the play and the bed and the sex
and the window like I I just I really I
couldn't I agree and honestly McAfee is
one of my least favorite characters and
she was like a bigger part this season
and I just didn't I just didn't like
that but something that I wanted to say
that I found really interesting was the
episode about the voter where that girl
was an intern and they kind of made it
seem like this whole political divide in
our country is really old verse young
where I never really felt that way maybe
I'm just like not politically informed
enough but I never I don't feel like the
divide in this country as old people
first young people too you know not
necessarily I think that there are like
generational issues but I think that
that is something that is happened since
the beginning there's always gonna be
old people and young people who like
differ on the way that they see the
world just based on life experience
experiences so I think that you know
even in the 70s there was the young
people that were like you know Woodstock
and then there were the old people who
were you know World War two hmm so I
think that that's always gonna be a
common theme in society I think they
harped on it like too much very much and
it's weird because it's like a show
about politics that's not really
political and I was thinking about it I
was like for a show that's not political
it was too political and for a show that
is political it wasn't political enough
I totally agree it reminds me of veep in
a lot of ways yeah but I never watched
the last season of veep so maybe it
started to change but that show was not
political at all no it was the most
brilliant show where like it was
literally set in the White House and I
had no clue who anyone was ya know it
was really brilliant and I under
I think they they achieved that more
during season one but also because it
was a student body election so you know
it's not political issues right um and
so this season was different overall
it's just such a well-done show I mean
the outfits on Alice
oh yeah larium Queens I mean Astrid
saying that she can't afford to eat at
that restaurant but wearing a Louie
Vuitton jacket and carrying a different
Louboutin bag in every scene like it's a
little bit of a pothole for me I have a
question for you do you think that's
seen with Judith Light and one of pal
trunk days time was filmed during
quarantine 1,000% and so my next
question is do you think that the tech
issues were intentional I was thinking
how hard is it to film a video in your
house that's supposed to look like a
phone it was probably added in to make
it look more real like a FaceTime I
thought the same thing but then it begs
the question like they obviously planned
something else for the end because it
was sure there's only 7 episodes oh yeah
I think they cut production to get it
out for quarantine I think that they did
too but I actually I didn't feel RDH at
all about the end I thought it was like
just like full circle full circle with a
nice bow ribbon and I'm ready for the
next season yeah I really liked it it's
a fabulous show that you really can't
complain the musical elements I just
absolutely love every time Bend pod
singing and you know this happened last
season too like I wasn't in love with
the song that they chose but then I
ended up loving of the song that came
out on Spotify Ben plots cover of Vienna
actually loved Vienna but rivers love
Vienna but I loved river so I feel the
same way about the song selection this
season well no first he sang his own
song right like the tail end of it um
but yeah it's I mean it was already on
Spotify but no that was enjoyable and he
gave us like a real song I'll I've never
heard that song before I don't know what
it's from I don't know who sings it and
I loved every minute of it and honestly
like yes if I were needy Saanich I would
have conceded it was it was just that
powerful and also what's okay this is
what doesn't make sense the whole
election is generational old people are
voting for DD young people are but the
nursing home ballot box at infinity
stole was actually Ben's wind like that
doesn't make sense based on everything
they told us or maybe it's just that Ben
Platt is that good of a politician that
he's changing hearts and minds of old
people who have been set in their ways
politically for years yes maybe that was
the message
yes per infinity I wanted to kill like
when she stole that ballot box and then
brought it to the headquarters like are
you trouble Brewin his [ __ ]
life yeah she was out of control but I
actually really loved learning about how
zero ways the zero waste I thought it
was fascinating I did two minutes she
could keep all of her trash in one jar
for her for a whole year I actually
I like that too but then like when she
demanded that bed no but I think that's
also like a funny commentary you know it
doesn't have to be so absolutist like
there's all there's things that we can
all do to make the world a better
cleaner safer place um so I thought that
was interesting but I also did like the
the tactical elements of like how you
live a zero-waste life it didn't seem
that hard except for the worm farm
shower oh the shower yeah I wouldn't do
that but I could see like buying my own
jars oh that's like that hard yeah no
that's not that hard I think a lot of
people do that and I think more people
should do that canvas bags you reusing
shower water to boil the sky was like
I'm I drink my [ __ ] coffee that was so
funny and that was like the one thing
Ben Platt didn't do that was hysterical
right but like if he did all the other
things on that list like and he's
obviously a warrior for climate and also
the ret and if everyone else did the
rest of the things on that list like we
would be so much better off so I think
that's what they're trying to say is
like it doesn't have to be all or
nothing you can all just do something
and I think that's actually a great myth
I have a straw I think that is a great
message to take from the show especially
in this climate like everyone's just
doing their best and that is a message
it doesn't have to be all this way or
all that way like you can take a little
bit from each and be like this is how I
feel about something yes so I I just
thought was a fabulous show went and
when I was done with it I was really
looking for something to watch too I
decided to watch the Netflix original
Eurovision movie called fire saga and I
only watched it because Ben and I went
to we had the honor of going to
Eurovision last year in Tel Aviv with
TPG and there was a Netflix camera crew
there they filmed a lot of the footage
at the real Eurovision so I was like
damn this is exciting I thought maybe I
would get on TV but under my just felt
connected to the movie because I was
there and from the minute I started
watching the movie they filmed this euro
version at that euro version vision
Eurovision you're a vision and a lot of
the feedback that I got from people um
who disagreed with me not liking the
movie they were like it's European
humour you don't get your vision but
like I get it I was there so I just I
just want to say from the minute I
turned on the movie I knew I was going
to absolutely hate it not to be you know
mean but Rachel McAdams was so miscast
I can't believe she sullied her resume
something like that she's not funny and
she can't sing and the whole point is
that like her song is amazing blah blah
and they did what they did was in music
incredible they did what they did for
Jenny Lind where they had someone else
be rachel mcadams voice voice and their
Swedish and they actually no they're not
Swedish they're Icelandic and they
actually had this like amazing um I
think she was Icelandic singer sings
rachel mcadams parts and like that girl
should have gotten the role she the best
voice I'd ever heard literally besides
mine in my life and just the rachel
mcadams part wasn't adding up but she
didn't do a good Icelandic um accent
she's not funny like and she just like
she's just a Lee from the notebook like
it just wasn't adding up but like how
did Ali get to Iceland yeah you know
what I think just like logistically
speaking I think she got paid a lot
because it's nice yeah but I'm honestly
well feral like takes a lot of pride in
his comedy and I just can't believe he
really put out this piece of [ __ ] and
just on my quest to take down rotten
tomatoes like this movie got a 58 shall
we compare it with Georgia that's a fail
it got I got more than Georgia rule
already tried to real good I don't know
but not good but 58 is a failing remark
and that means happen people liked it
half the people didn't like it but I
have more to say that Ben liked it well
Ben literally the most annoying person
watching movie with like couldn't not
stop cackling just because he loves will
family so he's the fifty hated the movie
he was like laughing at the dumb like
Icelandic like accent stuff but like it
just what it wasn't funny but I think
that's what Netflix movies are supposed
to be just think something to watch
they're not gonna okay but it was
actually bad like I felt like I really
wasted my life except I have to give
amateur credit they did the most amazing
thing where there was like this you know
after party for all the Eurovision
contestants like after the semi-finals
and it was kind of like pitch perfect
where they do like a sing-along
yeah and they had all these amazing
singers and some of them looked really
familiar and I was googling it and these
are all people who have participated in
Eurovision so I recognized the girl from
Israel who won therefore having Israel
host in Tel Aviv
Netta bard solidly like she's like a
she's like a global icon now so I
recognized her I'm like Tim are all
these people Eurovision contestants from
different countries and they are so they
were all performing this like medley of
different like pop songs in this
Eurovision party and that was really
good like that musical medley and then
the final song were incredible but it
didn't nearly carry the movie in the way
that it needed to it was so dumb okay
well honestly oh and then sorry Pierce
Brosnan it was in the movie love him as
Will Ferrell's dad like it just it
wasn't adding up for me Peter's
president as a fisherman an Icelandic
port loves his town it just it wasn't
adding up okay I don't think I have any
time to watch this I would you don't
have so much homework every single day
and night um so I don't think I'll ever
be watching it so thanks for the recap
so speaking of homework speaking of
homework
our toast movie of the week was black
clansmen which is a Spike Lee film that
was nominated for a bunch of Oscars
true story based on a true story and I
hadn't seen it but I knew that it was
about a black person in the Klan gave
him the title um and I just thought it
was fabulous like I loved the main
character who is Denzel Washington's son
you just told me that this morning and I
know that because he was in ballers
which is my favorite show and I just I'm
glad he's getting like the recognition
he deserves and I feel like he's not
like a lot of people who are children of
like famous actors like they're always
just like in their parents movies like
ma DAPA talaq yeah we're like posting on
Instagram yeah you would never know that
he was Denzel his son and I feel like he
gets the roles like based on his own
marriage ya know he is a fabulous actor
he did an amazing job and I got sad
story but it was like funny no it was
also it was funny it's a sad story
honestly like anything to do with the
KKK like Oh makes my stomach hurt but
ultimately and they added I looked up
like facts versus embellishments
afterwards and so they added some stuff
which we'll talk about but ultimately
it's a it's a triumphant story you know
um we're of good versus evil a good
versus evil exactly I thought that the
cast was really good so here are some
things that weren't in this photo he had
written a book ron stalin and so first
of all the person who goes undercover on
his behalf is not jewish in real life
but you know what usually i don't like
when they change true stories but i
think that added a really interesting
element i think it added a lot to but
also it really adds to my number one
thought of the movie is how poorly run
this police investigation was because
honestly sending a jewish person like
and i'm jewish I can say this like Adam
driver is visibly Jewish like he has a
big nose like it
not to be stereotypical but like sorry I
didn't know he was I didn't know Adam
driver is Jewish yes Rosie I'm pretty
sure I feel like he could not be so I
think that the police investigation
sending Adam driver in as a Jewish
character like was so dumb using Rahn
Stallworth surreal name so does what
happened in real like I know but then
wait sending knowing that a KKK member
went to Ron stall Worth's apartment and
then sending Ron star worth to be David
blanks police body there was so much
crossover and then also Laura Harrier
like knowing who were on saw birth is
what he does like at one point the I
thought they were all gonna link up you
know he was all gonna come together
Colorado Springs is just the smallest
plate and by the way like the KKK
members of the KKK that they were so
dumb like they would never have figured
out the investigation but they made it
so easy for these morons to figure it
out yes yeah the David Duke parts were
just like chilling I feel like they
really encapsulated like his whole weird
like MLM you know like chapters like it
was it was just freaking me out yeah it
was it was chilling I'm sorry I take it
back but so what you have to get into
the mind of a KKK person like they see a
big nose and they're like jiù jiù jiù
okay well they didn't even mention his
nose well that's Venus thing was
interesting yeah but most people are
surprised not the only Jewish people I
thought that too and like like again
those members of the KKK they weren't
like the smartest people oh no no they
couldn't even pull off like their one
job you know which was that a bomb also
were you getting the vibe at the end
that maybe the police chief was like KKK
yeah he was like I have your back in the
very beginning I mean I'm like he's a
good one then he never had his back not
one and then in the end he just like
completely cut it off I thought when
they were doing the cross burning and
they were like showing a little bit on
under people's masks I thought that he
might have been there that's an
interesting call what I was confused
about is who was at the door who was at
the door oh when they knock yeah and
then the movie ended and they just
showed them burning the cross like did
they die no no book no yeah I don't
think he's at the door I think it's just
like was they reason for them to open
the door I don't know I guess they could
have had the window of the Cross burning
like through his apartment yeah I'm just
curious about that and also if we saw
his apartment when Felix went to go see
it he lived in a hallway so if like he
couldn't see out of it outside because
he was in this hallway
you know yes maybe they were at her
house so some other elements that were
added oh yeah
the end where they got that bad cop you
know and oh that fella facing that was
that didn't happen but I I as for
entertainment value it added so much
because like it really was like hit
inducing to see that guy have that sort
of power um also I think the whole plot
with the bomb and the Student Union
didn't really have they just like moved
the letter and I was like that wasn't
really a thing totally fair and he and
Ron saw birth was not dating the
president of the Black Student Union but
I like that storyline someone during
this whole got an undercover
investigation so and you know what I
liked about is like they added stuff
that wasn't true but it only added to
the story it didn't take away from the
message or the history 100% yeah that's
what we were talking about but honestly
like this type of movie this is what I
said about headed figures and similar
and Argo was like these amazing stories
in history that like I never heard about
yeah and if it weren't for these movies
maybe I never would have yeah so I I
think it was a great selection I just
loved it yeah I think it was a great
selection to some of the like way that
it was filmed was kind of confusing me
like when there was audio from one scene
in one scene it was really part of the
next scene I was like what rate are what
station are we listening to oh but it
was really like David Duke on the phone
no actually I agree with that a lot of
the radio scenes I was like who are we
listening to it was a little confusing I
agree and you had to like listen I'm
like is this a racist person like it was
I agree but then I also felt like there
were some really strong scenes like when
they're two back-to-back meetings oh yes
but also when they were at the shooting
range and then Ron Stallworth like goes
to the range and then he sees what they
were the targets and you only see his
expression before you see what it is and
I thought that the way that they did
that was very powerful
yeah the minute like hey this frame is
safe on there for like a long time ya
know it was really like an art film in
addition to being like historically
telling it was very well done the music
selection was groovy the outfits were
groovy I loved like all the the hair
like I thought it was really like an
accurate reflection of the time and it
was like done like kind of fabulously
yeah it was done really well I'm so glad
that we watched it
I'm actually really enjoying um me to
everything like about the new toast
movie of the week I feel like we're
learning so much and in a way that's
like an entertainer watching all of
these movies that are just supporting
black directors black artists black
actors yeah but that are major you know
Oscar contenders we never really watch
the Oscar movies Perry in and so now I
just like it's a change it's a change
and I'm really really enjoying it so for
our next film I'm gonna give back a
little clue tell me if you think the
audience can guess what movie it is okay
one day when the glory come honestly I'm
like being disgraceful to the song I'm
gonna stop but at Selma its Selma and I
like me what it was it was like I don't
know if I would have known but yeah I
know that song is great John Legend and
common won an Oscar for yeah but when
you were singing it I don't know if I
would have known what you were singing
oh so such a good song I'm really
excited to watch Selma's never stopping
that next Tuesday because we have a long
holiday weekend there'll be no show on
Friday or Monday but Tuesday will be
back recapping Selma so please watch
along with us yes fabulous anything else
we want to recap before we go I just
cannot you know press my comedy special
enough if you pre-ordered it it'll be
available tonight at midnight I think
and yeah it'll be available a ton of
other places so I cannot wait for
everyone to see ya and if you're looking
for more content head over to
patreon.com session morning toast we
have one more episode coming at you this
month and the last few episodes are
getting really rave reviews so check it
out thank you guys so much for listening
to the morning to--some on a morning
show where we go live Monday through
Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on
YouTube so if you're watching us on
YouTube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcast can be found on Spotify iTunes
stitcher Public Radio IRA their cast box
all the places wherever you listen to
podcast find us somewhere new to us and
leave a five-star review about a
beautiful stunning and smart we are we
love you guys so much and we'll see you
tomorrow bye